y a tomas la primera mujer trans en
ganar el campeonato de natación
universitario de eeuu esperaba
clasificarse para el equipo olímpico en
2024 pero bajo el nuevo reglamento de la
fina la federación internacional de
natación no es elegible para competir
mientras los mundiales de natación
tienen lugar en budapest la fina voto
prohibir que las mujeres trans compitan
a nivel de élite si han pasado parte de
la pubertad masculina
ahora tenemos que proteger los derechos
de todos nuestros atletas a competir
pero también tenemos que proteger la
competición justa en todos nuestros
eventos
a word especialmente en las
competiciones femeninas women's
competition el 71% de las 152
federaciones nacionales que conforman la
fina votaron a favor de la nueva
prohibición con base en un informe de un
panel científico del organismo que
estipula que las mujeres trans tienen
una ventaja significativa sobre las
nadadoras cis género incluso tras
disminuir médicamente sus niveles de
testosterona
defensores de los derechos lgtb
argumentan que no hay suficientes
estudios sobre atletas trans de élite y
temen que la decisión sirva de
precedente para que otras federaciones
deportivas tomen el mismo camino louis
si no se es joven chica esta política de
la fina tendrá un impacto enorme sobre
las normas en otros estados esto para mí
es el crimen real el hecho de que esta
política puede terminar afectando a un
menor de 14 años en el instituto
que me pone triste davis a la fina
asegura que establecerá una categoría
abierta para mujeres trans en algunos
eventos pero la decisión intensifica el
debate
los atletas trans mientras el mundo del
deporte intenta que la competición sea
justa e inclusiva algunos ven estos
esfuerzos como discriminatorios